welcome to this video playing p for ad
from spain named zoe up limbs Oh Abby
six seven ok let's transpose back to the
dash always getting interesting
positions with it we get to them to the
main line which is also following the
standard recipe and fortunately I forgot
how it is continued the special b3 here
I think this first
okay yeah this is one possible line this
is based on the idea that after d6
uh-huh okay d 6 I can take on f5 and
Dave even Bishop f5 because of Queen d5
don't don't no kuni 5 which doesn't mean
much I have mostly em looked at this
opening from the black side
okay try to get closer to the king
now I need to use the rookie on the
deform 27 s son this week
and I wanted to protect also I wanted to
protect the bishop so that i can play
Queen f-22 taxi five it's only all a big
bit shaky I was just covering it but
this look sir looks like looks a bit
passive those those pieces they're not
not really a participating okay um and
the same issue really should strike
while the iron is hot let's see can I
take on f5
this Bishop is not playing this is this
is maybe a move Queen d525 and still
intending to a second f5
yeah this dangerous so he's covering
covering it partly still okay you don't
really mind if he takes c3 window sir
would just open up the position for me
this bishop on d2l only three why should
it go to edge for a small idea on d to
protecting c3 once and for all as I said
I don't mind him to take it but if he
doesn't take it it's even better let's
do that I have the simple idea to to
double on the EVO
okay let's let's go for it very
complicated position now I can have this
the square attacking e7 and intending
night edge yeah okay come on if you
don't suck this moment you will never
second Queen age six and rook eat 3g
three also this check look III have come
on this must be right
okay let's let's look at this now check
HERE Kentucky echo check here yeah check
check check mate yep yeah pretty typical
Zemus game somehow it's a it's very
murky not not quite sure what what was
going on really here this this looks
this looks promising for me I think his
King side is a bit bare I mean look at
this it's the only defense that he's got
the end all those pieces off off site
but it's not really wasn't really
working too great not quite sure with
this son
it's it's dangerous in a practical game
but I'm not sure about the objective
merit of all this here night f1 the move
pointed out by the computer yeah Queen
g3 the idea but this shouldn't be too
bad and now i can even i can sacrifice
immediately check check and this seems
to win according to the comp yeah it is
a strong attack my idea we need to
however shouldn't be so bad yeah it
forecasts also win yeah I didn't
calculate but if you don't sacrifice
their you you you really shouldn't play
this opening so and winning yeah it's
even a forced meet and one of the force
mates was check was on the board so
check come on quite a fine one with all
so many pieces around the king and it's
a pure made he cannot interpose it's
just checkin made nice alright thanks
for watching